This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Doing better than your parents, having a better education, living a better life, this is universally seen as a good thing. But a century ago, a poet named Christo Smirnanski wrote a parable that raises important questions about the nature of upward mobility. The tale of the stairs is about an impoverished young man standing at the foot of a marble staircase. He's gazing up at the wealthy people above him. Quarer, enjoy in themselves and having drinks while the people down below don't have enough food to eat and are really suffering.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹坦。比父母过得好、接受更好的教育、过上更好的生活，这在普遍看来是一件好事。但在一个世纪前，一位名叫克里斯托·斯米尔纳斯基的诗人写过一则寓言，引发了人们对向上流动本质的重要思考。《阶梯的故事》讲述了一个贫困的年轻人站在大理石阶梯脚下。他凝视着上方的富人。他们在尽情享受、饮酒作乐，而下方的人却食不果腹、备受折磨。
This is philosopher Jennifer Morton. Blocking the young man's ascent to the party above is the devil himself. The devil asks him if he wants to get closer to the top. There's just one catch. The devil wants a bribe. The young man protests. I am poor, a youth and rags, he says. But I'm willing to give up my life. The devil says he doesn't want the young man's life.
这位是哲学家詹妮弗·莫顿。挡住年轻人通往上方派对去路的正是恶魔本人。恶魔问他是否想离山顶更近一些。只有一个条件。恶魔想要贿赂。年轻人抗议道。他说，我很穷，是个衣衫褴褛的年轻人，但我愿意放弃我的生命。恶魔说他并不想要年轻人的命。
He wants to replace his hearing with a new pair of ears. The young man agrees. And so, the devil lets him walk up a few steps. Now he can no longer hear the people below who are moaning out of hunger and distress. The young man is still only part way up the stairs. To go higher, the devil asks him to trade in his eyes for a new pair. And he can no longer see the people moaning down below and who are suffering. He's near the top. The devil asks for a final bribe. He wants to replace the young man's memory and his heart.
他想要用一双新耳朵替换年轻人的听力。年轻人同意了。于是，恶魔让他向上走了几步。现在他再也听不到下面那些因饥饿和痛苦而呻吟的人了。年轻人此时还只走到了阶梯的一半。为了走得更高，恶魔要求他用双眼换取一双新眼。这样他就再也看不到下面那些呻吟和受苦的人了。他已经接近山顶。恶魔提出了最后的贿赂。他想替换年轻人的记忆和心脏。
The young man protests, but the devil assures him a better heart and a new memory. The young man is now at the very top. His face is radiant. The crowds he sees below are in fancy clothes and their mones are now hymns. So by the time he gets to the top and he is there with the other wealthy and well-to-do people,
年轻人进行抗议，但恶魔向他保证会给他一颗更好的心和一段新记忆。年轻人现在已经站在了最顶端。他的脸光芒四射。他看到下方的人群穿着华丽的衣服，他们的抱怨声现在变成了赞美诗。因此，当他到达顶端并与其他富有和优渥的人在一起时，
he can no longer even really recognize the problems down the low where he came from. The young man has forgotten the people he left behind. As a parable, it's a powerful warning about the dangers of wealth and luxury. But in the real world, not all who climb that marble staircase are indifferent to the problems they've left behind. Many in fact are deeply torn about what it means to climb the economic and social ladder. This week on Hidden Brain we consider the complex trade-offs involved in climbing the ladder of upward mobility. The Termination, Enterprise, and Sacrifice have long been core ingredients in the story of the American Dream.
他甚至再也无法真正认出他出身的那个底层的各种问题。年轻人已经忘记了他抛在身后的人们。作为一个寓言，它对财富和奢侈的危险发出了强烈的警告。但在现实世界中，并非所有攀登大理石阶梯的人都对他们抛在身后的问题漠不关心。事实上，许多人对攀登经济和社会阶梯意味着什么感到深深的纠结。本周的《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们探讨了攀登向上流动阶梯所涉及的复杂权衡。决心、企业精神和牺牲长期以来一直是美国梦故事的核心要素。
Philosopher Jennifer Morton argues there is another less obvious ingredient in the story of upward mobility, a willingness to make ethical trade-offs. She doesn't mean lying or cheating, but something subtler and far more consequential. Jennifer Morton, welcome to Hidden Brain. I'm delighted to be here, Shankar. So what are some of the classic ingredients we recognize in strivers, the people who are on this path to upward mobility? What are the ingredients that we think go into the American dream? For the most part, it's drivers are, as you might expect, ambitious,
哲学家詹妮弗·莫顿认为，向上流动的故事中还有另一个不太明显的成分，那就是进行伦理权衡的意愿。她指的不是撒谎或作弊，而是更微妙、影响更深远的事情。詹妮弗·莫顿，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里，香卡。那么，在我们认同的奋斗者身上，也就是那些走在向上流动道路上的人身上，有哪些经典特质呢？我们认为构成美国梦的要素有哪些？在很大程度上，正如你所料，奋斗者是有野心的、
hardworking, smart, but also I think are willing to make trade-offs in the pursuit of those ambitions. And some of those trade-offs, in some cases, are quite difficult and painful. You've spent much of the last decade teaching at a school that wanted to give people a shot at the American dream. I understand students at the City College of New York don't usually come from the one percent? Yes.
工作努力、聪明，但我也认为他们在追求这些野心时愿意做出权衡。其中一些权衡在某些情况下相当困难和痛苦。在过去十年的大部分时间里，你一直在一家希望给人一个实现美国梦机会的学校教书。据我了解，纽约城市学院的学生通常不是来自那百分之一的富裕阶层吧？是的。
Most of our students come from working- class families, immigrant families, or their immigrants themselves. Many of them come from families that make less than $20,000 a year. And they see City College as a ticket to the middle class, to having better lives than the ones that their parents have, or then maybe the people in their neighborhood have. And the city called to New York has held this place and the imagination of New Yorkers for a long time. So, you know, when it started, it was a school that accepted Jewish immigrants when they weren't accepted elsewhere.
我们的学生大多来自工人阶级家庭、移民家庭，或者他们自己就是移民。他们当中有许多人的家庭年收入低于两万美元。他们将城市学院视为通往中产阶级的入场券，视为过上比父母更好、或者比他们社区里的人更好的生活的一种途径。纽约城市学院在纽约人的想象中长期占据着这样的地位。所以，你知道，当它刚创办时，是一所接纳犹太移民的学校，而当时他们在其他地方是不被接纳的。
It used to be free and it was called the Harvard of the Poor by many because it was a place where the brightest and smartest kind of working class kids could go and really have a shot at transforming their lives through education. have a shot at transforming their lives through education. Jennifer found that more than three quarters of the students at City College were people of color and nearly half were the first in their families to go to college. But as exciting as it was to teach these drivers, Jennifer Sessie regularly heard from students dealing with a variety of crises on the home front. Family drama in the words of one student. I didn't cry to find out exactly what was going on, but later as I taught at City College
它过去是免费的，许多人称之为“穷人的哈佛”，因为它是一个让最聪明、最机智的工人阶级孩子去并通过教育真正获得改变命运机会的地方。获得通过教育改变命运的机会。詹妮弗发现，城市学院四分之三以上的学生是有色人种，近一半是家族中第一代上大学的人。但尽管教导这些奋斗者令人兴奋，詹妮弗说她经常听到学生们处理后方各种危机的情况。用一个学生的话来说，就是家庭闹剧。我并没有去深究到底发生了什么，但后来我在城市学院教书
for many years, I sort of uncovered what this family drama phrase meant. And what it meant for many of my students who felt comfortable enough with me to share was that they had families who were going through a lot. For example, people whose parents were getting kicked out of housing or who themselves were homeless, I had a student whose mother became disabled and couldn't work anymore and the disability checks weren't enough to cover all their expenses and so she had to work full-time as well as attend college full-time. I've had students who had to do childcare for extended family because child
很多年后，我逐渐弄明白了“家庭闹剧”这个词的意思。对于许多与我足够亲近而愿意分享的学生的来说，这意味着他们的家庭正在经历很多变故。例如，有些人的父母被赶出住所，或者他们自己无家可归；我曾有个学生，她的母亲残疾了，无法再工作，残疾抚恤金不足以支付所有的开销，所以她不得不一边全职工作，一边全职上大学。我还有过一些学生，因为托儿服务泡汤了，或者表亲去面试时负担不起托儿费用，他们不得不帮大家庭照顾孩子。
care fell through or a cousin couldn't afford child care when they were going to a job interview. And so what I saw was that my students were playing all sorts of care, taking and financial support roles for their families and extended families and often even members of their community. And they were having all of that on their shoulders as well as trying to study for exams, write papers, and do well in college. Hmm. Now lots of students face challenges in college. Lots of students make sacrifices,
因此我看到的是，我的学生们在为他们的家庭、大家庭甚至社区成员扮演着各种照顾者和经济支持者的角色。他们把这一切都扛在肩上，同时还要准备考试、写论文以及在大学里取得好成绩。嗯。现在很多学生在大学里都会面临挑战。很多学生都在做牺牲，
and in fact, this is true of the workplace as well. You know, the banker who's working 80 hours a week might be giving up a social life. The musician who's trying to get into the local orchestra might be sacrificing, you know sacrificing her health or sleep. But the challenges that your students were facing felt qualitatively different to you, and you included that there was an ethical component
事实上，职场中也是如此。你知道，每周工作80个小时的银行家可能会放弃社交生活。试图进入当地乐团的音乐家可能会牺牲，你知道的，牺牲她的健康或睡眠。但你的学生们所面对的挑战让你感觉有质的不同，你认为这些挑战中包含着一个伦理成分。
to these challenges. What do you mean by that? What happens with strivers is that in order to succeed in higher education, they often have to deal with the fact that their parents, families, communities need them, and it becomes very hard for them to navigate both trying to succeed in college and to be caring sisters, sons, daughters, friends, or community members. So if you're going to classes and studying for exams, you might not have enough time to, for example, take care of a little
你这话是什么意思？奋斗者身上发生的情况是，为了在高等教育中取得成功，他们往往必须应对这样一个事实：他们的父母、家庭、社区需要他们，这使得他们很难在努力在大学取得成功与成为一个有爱心的兄弟、姐妹、儿子、女儿、朋友或社区成员之间找到平衡。因此，如果你去上课并准备考试，你可能就没有足够的时间，比如去照顾需要照顾的小表弟，或者带你的祖母去医院。
cousin who needs care or take your grandmother to the hospital. And so what happens is that these students end up feeling torn between doing the things that would seem to be required by being, to say, a good grandson and doing the things that are required to be a successful student. And so your sense was that these trade-offs or these sacrifices that students were being
于是发生的情况是，这些学生最终会感到左右为难：一方面要做一个好孙子似乎要求去做的事，另一方面要做一个成功的学生所要求做的事。所以你的感觉是，学生们被要求做出的这些权衡或牺牲涉及对他们的家庭或社区、甚至可能是他们的身份的牺牲，而你的直觉是，在许多方面，这些牺牲涉及伦理权衡。为什么是伦理，詹妮弗？
asked to make involve sacrifices about their families or their communities, perhaps even their identities, and your sense was that in many ways these sacrifices involved an ethical trade-off. Why ethics, Jennifer? Yeah, I think often we don't necessarily think about ethics as playing a role here, but I think whenever a person is caught between trying to figure out what the right thing to do is when, on the one hand, they feel the obligation or the desire to help somebody that they love. And on the other, they also feel the desire
是的，我认为我们往往不会必然地认为伦理在其中发挥了作用，但我觉得每当一个人陷入两难境地，试图弄清楚什么是正确的事情时——一方面，他们感受到帮助自己所爱之人的义务或愿望；另一方面，他们也感受到追求自己道路的愿望。他们在平衡和权衡这两种构成美好繁盛生活的两个重要且有价值的维度。我认为这些情况特别令人悲伤的是，奋斗者往往会内化他们做出的一些决定，并认为自己是个“坏儿子、坏姐姐、坏弟弟或坏朋友”，因为我最终去上课或复习考试了，而不是陪在我爱的人身边。我想，这就是奋斗者所处的令人心酸且艰难的伦理困境。
to succeed in their own path. They're balancing and trading off against each other, two important and valuable dimensions of what a good and flourishing life would entail. And I think what's particularly sad about these cases is that strivers will often internalize some of the decisions they make and think of themselves as, I was a bad son or a bad sister or a bad brother or a bad friend because I ended up going to class or studying for my exam, instead of being there for this person that I love. And that's, I think, the really kind of poignant and difficult ethical position that strivers are in.
所以你决定不仅在你的学生中探讨这个想法，而且要在更广泛的范围内探讨。事实上，其中一个案例研究我想能很好地概括你所谈论的想法。我希望你给我描述几个这样的案例故事。一个你称之为托德的年轻人告诉你，他在亚特兰大长大，请告诉我托德童年的情况。托德在亚特兰大大体上属于非裔美国人的路因甘社区长大，他和时而失业的妈妈以及祖父母一起住在祖父母家里。他的整个家族
So you decided to explore this idea not just among your students but more broadly. And in fact, one of these case studies I think might encapsulate really well the ideas you're talking about. I want you to describe a few of these case stories to me. A young man whom you call Todd told you he grew up in Atlanta telling me the circumstances of Todd's childhood. Todd grew up in predominantly African-American Lewin gum neighborhood of Atlanta and he grew up with his mom who was in and out of work and with his grandparents and his grandparents home. His whole family
都与这个社区有着很深的渊源。所以他妈妈曾就读于当地的公立学校，他的表亲们住在社区里，祖父母的家可以说是他大家庭以及社区里朋友的枢纽。因此，他的家族非常融入那个社区。现在托德在公立学校上学，但他不喜欢那里，因为他因正如他所说试图表现得像个白人而被取笑。
had been well connected to this neighborhood. So his mom had gone to the local public school, his cousins lived in the neighborhood, and his grandparents' home was kind of a hub for his extended family in France in the neighborhood. And so his family was very well integrated into that community. Now Todd was going to the public school, but he didn't like it because he was teased for,
对他来说，这意味着他试图取得好成绩并表现出色，他觉得学生们以此为由取笑和欺凌他。托德的母亲在某个时候决定托德必须离开那所学校，因为学校里曾有老师被刺伤，所以她认为托德需要去一所不同的学校。接着，她找到了一位住在亚特兰大较富裕郊区的朋友，这位朋友允许他们使用自己的地址，以便托德能去一所郊区的磁石学校上学。
as he said, trying to be white. What that meant for him was that he was trying to get good grades and do well, and he felt that the students were teasing him and bullying him on the basis of that. Todd's mother decided at some point that Todd needed to leave that school because the teacher had gotten stabbed in the school and so she thought Todd needed to go to a different school. She then found a friend who lived in a more wealthy suburb of Atlanta and who allowed them to use her address in order for Todd to go to a suburban magnet school.
于是他们撒了谎，让托德得以进入这所不同的学校，托德的生活从那时起发生了戏剧性的变化。这所学校为他提供了他在当地公立学校所没有的学术机会。与他一起上学的大多数人都是中产阶级或上中产阶级，是医生和牙医的儿子女儿等等。这所学校里的每个人都志在大学，这在公立学校是不可能的。有时开始过着两种生活。
So they lied to get Todd to go to this different school and Todd's life changed pretty dramatically at that point. The school offered him academic opportunities that he didn't have at his local public school. Most of the people that he went to school with were middle class, or upper middle class, the sons and daughters of doctors and dentists, and so on. And everybody at this school was college bound, which was not true at his public school. And sometimes started living kind of two lives.
他会去郊区的磁石学校，结交种族更多元的朋友。正如他所描述的那样，他原来的学校是100%黑人。这所学校里有很多白人学生、更富裕的学生，还有更多的学术机会。然后他回到家，重新回到他的社区，托德形容自己有时会感到羞耻对自己的出身感到羞耻，并对学校的朋友和学校朋友的父母隐瞒这一点。
He would go to the suburban magnet school and have friends who were more ethnically diverse. His school had been as he described it 100% black. The school was, there were a lot of white students, much wealthier students, more academic opportunities. And then he would come home and be back in his neighborhood and Todd described kind of feeling sometimes ashamed opportunities, and then he would come home and be back in his neighborhood and taught the scribe kind of feeling sometimes ashamed about where he came from and hiding
托德最终基本上从朋友那里学会了如何申请大学，并且成了家族中第一个上大学的人。在大学期间，托德住在上大学的地方，但他仍然会回家。所以他在家里的车程范围内。他仍然会回家看望祖父母，并试图与他的社区保持联系。
that from his school friends and his school friends parents. Todd eventually picked up basically from his friends how to apply to college and was the first person in his family to go to college. While at college taught lived where he went to college, but he would still go back home. So he was writing distance from home. He would still go back home and visit his grandparents and try to stay connected to his community.
但渐渐地，随着托德在大学里取得成功，他开始与家人疏远，接着当祖父母去世时，他回家越来越少。所以一旦托德大学毕业，你提到在祖父母去世后，他开始失去与家乡社区的一些联系。跟我聊聊这个。你写到他仍然与一些人保持联系，但其中一些谈话变得非常尴尬和困难。
But little by little, as Todd starts to succeed in college, he starts to distance himself from his family, and then when his grandparents die, he starts going home less and less. So once Todd graduates from college, you mentioned that after his grandparents died, he started to lose some ties to his home community. Talk to me a little bit about that. You write about how he was still in touch with some people, but some of those conversations became very awkward and difficult.
这是为什么呢？是的，所以托德在联邦政府获得了一份享有声望的实习工作并搬到了东北部。他非常平静地与妹妹交谈，但这些谈话变得非常困难，因为他的妹妹总是抱怨他没有寄足够多的钱回家。所以托德一开始工作就立刻开始往家里寄钱。但他的妹妹认为这远远不够。因此谈话变得非常紧张，这使得托德不想给妹妹打电话，因为他觉得我们又要为钱争吵了。
Why was that? Yeah, so Todd got a prestigious internship with a federal government and moved to the Northeast. He was so calm to talk to his sister especially, but those conversations got very difficult because his sister was always complaining about not sending enough money home. So Todd had started to send money back to his family as soon as he started working. But his sister thought it was never enough. And so the conversations got very tense and it would make it hard for Todd to want to call his sister because he thought we're going to have another argument
这导致了进一步的疏远。所以有趣的是，在每一步中，你都可以看到托德是如何脱离或者觉得不得不脱离那些对他作为一个人至关重要的事情——他的家庭、他的社区、他的身份。当他在学校时，回到他旧的社区，你知道，搬到磁石学校意味着结交了一群拥有新社会规范的新朋友。当他搬到大学时，这意味着采纳大学同龄人的规范和态度，
about money. And so this led to further distancing. So it's interesting in every step of the way you can sort of see how Todd was disengaging or felt like he had to disengage from things that were very core to him as a person, his family, his community, his identity. When he was in school, back in his old neighborhood, you know, moving to the magnet school meant a new set of friends with a new set of social norms. When he moved to college, it meant adopting the norms and attitudes of his peers in college,
这些规范和态度在某些方面与他家乡的朋友和邻居的规范和态度非常不同。当他最终开始工作时，他发现与家人的谈话变得非常紧张，因为家人依靠他来支持他们。他很乐意在某种程度上做到这一点，但他觉得他们只想谈论钱。你可以看到在每一步中，托德与他的过去、他的根基的联系是如何变得脱节的？是的，还有一个有趣的事情是，许多围绕金钱的艰难对话源于他的家人并没有真正理解托德的处境。在他们眼中，他赚了很多钱，但当然他住在华盛顿特区，维持着一套公寓，
which were in some ways very different from the norms and attitudes of his friends and neighbors back home. And as he eventually started working, he found that conversations with his family became very fraught, because the family relied on him to support them. And he was happy to do that to some extent, but he felt like all they wanted to talk about was money. And you can see at each step how Todd's connection with his past, his roots is it a becoming disengaged? Yes, and one interesting thing was also that a lot of the conversations around money that were difficult stem from his family not really understanding Todd's situation. To their eyes he was making a lot of money, but of course he was living in DC and kept up an apartment
过着这种中产阶级生活有很多开销是很大的。从他家人的角度来看，这并不完全说得通。因此，在理解上也存在脱节，不仅仅是他变得越来越像他大学或工作时的那些人，而是他的家人并不完全理解托德所进入的这个新世界。有趣的是，如果你从外部来看托德的生活，从我们的角度来看，你可能会说，你看，这是一个开局拿到一副烂牌的人。
and there were a lot of things that were kind of expensive about leading this middle-class life. And from his family's perspective, that didn't quite make sense. So there was a disconnect also in understanding from not just him kind of becoming more and more like the people he went to college with or he was working with, but his family not fully understanding this new world that Todd was head entered. The interesting thing is if you look at Todd's life from the outside, from our perspective, you might say, you know, here's someone who started out life with a deck stacked against him.
他想方设法给自己争取到了良好的教育，找到了一份很棒的工作。他显然是美国梦的标杆。而我们在某种程度上没有看到的是水面之下发生的事情，你所谈论的所有这些事情。是的，我认为我们没有看到的是，
And he figured out a way to get himself a good education and get himself a great job. And he's clearly, he's the standard bearer for the American dream. And what we're not seeing in some ways is what's happening under the surface, all these things you're talking about. Yeah, and I think what we're not seeing
随着托德失去了朋友，他与家庭的关系变得紧张，同样真实的是，他长大的那个社区、那些曾是朋友的人、他的大家庭、他的亲友也失去了一些东西。所以我想如果我们从双方来看，托德付出的伦理代价也反映了这个社区、那个家庭和那些朋友所付出的伦理代价。奋斗者经常被告知，你做出的权衡是好的。你在新生活中将建立的个人和社会关系会补偿你为之牺牲的那些关系。当我们回来时，为什么当涉及到我们的关系和身份时，交换和交易的逻辑会崩溃。
is that Estad loses friends and his relationships with his family gets strained, it's also true that the community grew up in those people he was friends with, his extended family, his family is losing somebody too. So I think if we look at it from both sides, the ethical cost that Todd pays also reflect an ethical cost paid by the community and that family in those friends. Strivers are often told that trade-offs you make are good. The personal and social relationships you will form in your new life will compensate you for the ones you have sacrificed. When we come back, why the logic of exchange and transaction breaks down when it comes
詹妮弗·莫顿是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的哲学家。在她的书《向上流动而不失本心》（Moving Up Without Losing Your Way）中，她探讨了集中面临社会不利条件的社区与走在向上流动道路上的那些来自这些社区的奋斗者之间交汇时产生的伦理代价。詹妮弗，如果你出生在一个不属于收入阶层底部10%并且你是黑人，你终其一生留在该收入阶层的几率是42%。你的许多朋友和亲戚也非常贫穷，因此对来自这样一个社区的许多奋斗者来说，成功通常意味着成功走出去。
to our relationships and our identity. Jennifer Morton is a philosopher at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill. In her book, Moving Up Without Losing Your Way, she explores the ethical costs that arise at the intersection of communities that face concentrated social disadvantage and the strivers from those communities who are on the path to upward mobility. Jennifer, if you're born into a family that isn't the bottom 10% of the income spectrum and you're black, you have a 42% chance of staying in that income band all your life. Many of your friends and relatives are also very poor, so making it for many strivers from such a community usually means making it out.
你能谈谈这个想法吗？也就是说，你所描述的问题的一部分与不利条件的集中有关，不仅在美国的社区内，而且在世界各地？是的，我认为奋斗者付出的伦理代价的一个重要部分，在于他们成长于贫困集中的社区这一事实。这意味着你在一个贫穷的家庭长大，但你也在结交朋友、建立联系并与一个每个人都处于类似境地的社区保持联系。因此你没有机会发展友谊
Can you talk about this idea for a moment, which is that part of the problem that you're describing has to do with the concentration of disadvantage, not just in communities within the United States, but across the world? Yes, I think an important part of the ethical costs that strivers pay and both the fact that they're growing up in communities in which poverty is concentrated. What that means is that you're growing up in a family that's poor, but you're also making friends and developing connections and being connected to a community in which everybody is in a similar situation. And so you don't have the chance to develop friendships
或者与许多中产阶级或上中产阶级建立关系，这会带来很多后果。首先，一旦你确实进入了大学或中产阶级的工作场所，你可能没有太多体验过充满这些空间的那些中产阶级人群的文化和规范。因此你可能会觉得自己是个局外人。
or relationships with a lot of middle class or upper middle class people, and there are a lot of consequences to that. The first is that once if you do make it into a college or a middle class workplace, you might not have had as much experience with the culture and the norms of the middle class people that populate those spaces. And so you might feel like an outsider.
但这也意味着，如果你要获得那些中产阶级的工作和机会，你将不得不离开你的社区为了获得那些中产阶级的工作和机会，你将不得不离开你的社区。你将不得不抛弃许多你爱的人、关心的人以及与你一同长大的人。而留在你的社区里，与你的朋友和大家庭呆在一起，通常意味着甘于贫困。
But it also means that if you're going to access those middle class jobs and opportunities, you're going to have to leave your neighborhood in order to access those middle class jobs and opportunities, you're going to have to leave your neighborhood in order to access them. And you're going to have to leave behind many of the people who you love and care about and you grow up with. And staying with your community, staying with your friends and your extended family, often means being resigned to stay in poverty.
当然，这不是我们对每个人都要求的选择。如果你在一个富裕的城市或繁荣的社区长大，你通常不必为了去一所好学校或找到一份好工作而离开你的邻居和社区。正是如此。因此，对于一个在集中贫困中长大的人来说，获得能将他们推入中产阶级的教育和职业机会需要离开他们的社区。中产阶级郊区的一个中产阶级学生，
And of course, this is not a choice we ask of everyone. If you grew up in a wealthy city or a prosperous community, you often don't have to leave your neighbors and communities in order to go to a good school or find a great job. Exactly. So for someone who grows up in concentrated poverty, accessing the kind of educational and career opportunities that would propel them into the middle class requires leaving their community. A middle class student in a middle class suburb
他想要离开去上一所寄宿学校，或者他们有一个去加利福尼亚之类的梦想，这是他们做出的选择，但不是为了过上他们的父母和周围人所拥有的那种中产阶级生活而必须做出的选择。所以我们都喜欢听那些贫困学生成为家族中第一个上大学的故事。你知道，我们为第一代大学生展现出的坚毅和决心鼓掌。我们通常不会过多讨论他们可能正在付出的社会和情感代价。我在想，这些代价是否正是你引用的那些惊人统计数据背后的原因：
who wants to leave to go to a boarding school or maybe they have a dream of going to California or something like that, that's a choice they're, but not a choice they're required to make in order to have the kind of middle-class life that their parents have and the people around them have. So we all love to hear stories of poor students who are the first in their families to go to college. You know, we applaud first-generation college students for their grit, for their determination. We don't usually talk very much about the social and emotional cost they might be paying. And I'm wondering if those costs might be behind some of the astonishing
入学低收入第一代大学生中只有21%真正完成学业，而其他学生的这一比例约为57%。是的，所以我们知道第一代和低收入学生在大学里面临着很多障碍。其中一些纯粹是财务上的，对吧？因此，除了学费之外，它可能还涉及书本费、住宿费或伙食费。但它也可能涉及他们的家庭能够做出的牺牲，
statistics you cite, only 21% of low-income first-generation students who enroll in college actually finish compared to about 57% of other students. Yes, so we know that first generation and low income students face a lot of obstacles in college. Some of these are purely financial, right? So it might involve the cost of books or the cost of housing or the cost of food in addition to the cost of tuition. But it might also involve the kind of sacrifices
以支持他们完成大学学业。因此我们知道，学生觉得很难完成学业这一事实背后有一个财务组成部分。但我认为我们没有讨论的一点是，对学生来说，成功可能会非常困难，在情感上、心理上和伦理上都很艰难，因为他们在帮助家庭、陪伴朋友、保持
that their families are able to make to support them through college. So we know that there's a financial component to the fact that students find it hard to finish college. But I think something we don't talk about is that for students, it can be very difficult, emotionally and psychologically and ethically to make it, because they feel torn between helping their families, being there for their friends, staying
与社区的联系以及在大学取得成功之间感到左右为难。当学生以这种方式感到纠结时，我认为有时他们认为“完成大学学业不值得我放弃这一切”是非常合理的。因此，我写这本书的目标之一就是帮助我们理解，一个人怎么会处于这样一种潜在情况：他们有向上流动的机会，但最终却放弃了，或者从大学退学，因为他们发现这些牺牲太大了。我想我们很多人都明白，如果我们被要求牺牲与朋友和家人的关系并与社区断开联系，即使我们这样做可以赚更多钱并找到更好的工作，我们可能也不会这么做。
connected to their communities, and succeeding in college. And when students feel torn in that way, I think sometimes it's very reasonable for them to think, well, I don't think finishing college is worth everything I'm giving up. So I think one of my goals in writing this book was to help us understand how someone could be in a situation where potentially they have this opportunity for upward mobility and they end up not taking it or dropping out of college because they find that the sacrifices are too much. I think many of us understand that if we were asked to sacrifice our relationships with our friends and family and become disconnected from our community, we might not do so even if we could
好吧，一旦你开始写这本书，你最好的学生之一，你称他为卡洛斯，就急于把他的故事告诉你。其中一些与涉及他弟弟的一系列非常令人不安的事件有关。詹妮弗，告诉我卡洛斯对你说了什么。他有着许多其他奋斗者都有的故事。
make more money and get a better job by doing so. Well, once you started working on the book, one of your best students whom you call Carlos was eager to tell you his story. And some of this had to do with a very troubling series of events involving his brother. Tell me what Carlos told you, Jennifer. He had the kind of story that a lot of other drivers have.
他是一个勤奋、聪明的孩子，考入了城市学院，但在卡洛斯上大学期间，他的弟弟一度被指控犯有强奸罪并入狱了。在弟弟出狱后，整个家庭要应对弟弟入狱以及试图为他寻找法律援助以获得良好辩护的整个过程，其实非常艰难。但接着一旦他出狱，他的弟弟就患上了精神疾病。这种精神疾病对卡洛斯、他的母亲以及一个在他生活中如同父母般存在的叔叔来说非常艰难。每个人都发现真的很难弄清楚该怎么办。他们负担不起弟弟需要的护理费用。最后，他的弟弟又回到了监狱。卡洛斯告诉我，他
He was hardworking, smart kid, made it into city college, but his brother got accused of rape at one point while Carlos was in college and went to prison. And after his brother left prison, it was actually very hard on the family to deal with this whole process of his brother, going to prison and trying to find legal aid for him to have a good defense. But then once he came out of prison, his brother developed a mental illness. And the mental illness was very hard on Carlos and his mother and a uncle that was kind of like a parental figure in his life. Everybody was finding it really hard to figure out what to do. They couldn't afford the kind of care his brother needed. And finally, his brother went back to prison. And Carlos told me that he
对弟弟回到监狱后自己感到的那种如释重负感到非常内疚，因为很显然他爱他的弟弟，但他也觉得应对弟弟的精神疾病真的摧毁了他继续追求高等教育和在生活中有所作为的能力。所以卡洛斯因为在弟弟回监狱时感到如释重负而觉得自己是个坏弟弟。但你知道，有人可能会对卡洛斯说，你看，换个角度想。一旦你找到了一份好工作并搬进了一个不错的中产阶级社区，你会交到很多朋友，并且你会拥有在某种程度上补偿你的关系。
felt so guilty about how relieved he felt once his brother went back to prison because obviously he loves his brother but he also felt like it was really destroying his ability to continue to pursue higher education and to make something of his life dealing with his brother's mental illness. So Carlos felt like a bad brother for feeling relieved when his brother went back to prison. But you know, someone might tell Carlos, you know, look at it this way. Once you get a good job and move into a nice middle class neighborhood, you're going to make lots of friends and you're going to have relationships that in some ways compensate you for the
你可能已经失去了这些关系。在许多方面，这种模式就是我们普遍考虑牺牲时的模式：你今天开一辆便宜的车，以便为明天买房支付首付省下钱。但你认为关系不是这样运作的。詹妮弗，这是为什么呢？所以，关系不符合这种权衡的经济模型的原
relationships that you might have lost. And in many ways, this model is the model we have when we think about sacrifices in general, you drive a cheap car today in order that you can save money to make a down payment on a house tomorrow. But you argue that relationships don't work this way. Why is that Jennifer? So the recent that relationships
因是，当我们爱一个人时，我们爱的是那个特定的人。你知道，我有一个迷人的三岁女儿，她非常搞笑，就像三岁小孩那样有点滑稽，想象一下，在某天早晨我醒来走进她的房间，里面的人不是她，而是另一个同样搞笑、同样滑稽的三岁小孩。你可能会说，好吧，你失去了你的女儿，但你现在可以照顾这个同样搞笑、同样滑稽的三岁小孩了。
don't fit this economic model of trade-offs is because when we love somebody, we love that particular person. You know, I have a charming three-year-old daughter who's very funny and a little loony is three-year-old to are and imagine that in the, you know, one morning I wake up and go into her room and it's not her, but it's another three-year-old who is equally funny and equally loony. And you might say, well, you lost your daughter, but there's this other equally funny, equally loony three-year-old you now get to take care of.
当然，如果发生这种事我会崩溃的，那是因为当我们爱一个人并对他们产生依恋时，我们不仅关心他们的品质或他们在我们生活中扮演的角色。我们关心的是他们，那个特定的人。当我们失去这一点时，我们就失去了一些在某种程度上无法替代的东西。正如任何失去过孩子的父母在最浪漫的情况下所知道的，但我认为我们大多数可能失去过友谊的人都知道，是的，当然你会结交新朋友，那些新朋友也很棒，但你可能仍然会哀悼失去的那位朋友，即使你
Of course, I would be devastated if that were to happen, and that's because when we love someone and we're attached to them, we don't only care about their qualities or the role that they play in our lives. We care about them, that particular person. And when we lose that, we lose something that in a way cannot be replaced. As any parent whose last a child knows in the most romantic case, but I think most of us who've maybe lost a friendship know that yeah of course you make new friends and those new friends are great, but you might still mourn the friend that was lost even as you
感谢你结交的新朋友。因此我认为，当奋斗者失去这些关系，或者这些关系可能因向上流动而变弱时，他们仍然有权利，而且有充分的理由去哀悼他们所失去的，即使从这些损失中可以获得很多东西。当然，我们之前已经暗示过这一点，当奋斗者离开他们的家乡和社区，当他们的新生活使他们难以保持与这些社区的联系时，承受损失的不仅是那个离开的人。
appreciate the new friends that you make. And so I think when strivers are losing these relationships or maybe those relationships are getting a weekend by upward mobility, they still have a right, I think, in good reason to mourn what they have lost, even if there is much to be gained from those losses. And of course, we've hinted at this earlier when strivers leave their homes and communities when their new lives make it difficult for them to retain their ties with those communities, the losses are not experienced merely by the person
在许多方面，对于那些被抛在身后的人来说，这种损失可能更加剧烈。是的，我认为是这样的。在我完成这本书后，我心中仍然存在的一个问题是，我采访了奋斗者，但我也想更多地了解他们的家庭和社区经历了什么，因为当奋斗者搬走或这些关系因向上流动带来的压力而破裂时，家庭、朋友、社区也失去了
who has left. In many ways, the losses may be even more acute for the people who have been left behind. Yes, I think that is right. And one of the questions that remains in my mind after having worked on this book is that I interviewed strivers, but I also wanted to know more about what their families and communities experience because families, friends, communities also lost
某个有价值的人。嗯-hmm。所以我很好奇家庭对此有何看法，留下来的人对以这种方式失去某人有何看法。而且，你知道，有时我们在移民的背景下讨论这个想法，我们说，你知道的，我们称之为“人才流失”。
someone valuable when the striver moved away or when those relationships were fractured by the stress of upward mobility. Mm-hmm. And so I wonder what the family think about that and what the members of the community that stay back think about having lost someone in this way. And, you know, we talk about this idea sometimes in the context of migration where we say, you know, that we call this brain drain.
但我认为你所指出的是一个更微妙的重点。这不仅仅是关于有才华的人离开一个社区去别的地方。你还失去了一个在你生活中具有重要关系的人。换句话说，当有人离开你的社区时，除了任何形式的专业或智力损失之外，还有情感损失？是的，我认为这种损失有可能让你的生活变得更糟，至少在一段时间内是这样的，对吧？我认为大流行病让我们有了一种认识到这一点的方式，对吧？因为我们中的一些人正在感受到距离带来的那种损失，以及它如何让我们的生活不如以前那么丰富。因此我认为，在某种程度上，我们可以体会到那种不得不与我们所爱和关心的人保持距离的体验，并感到由于这一点我们的生活不如以前丰富。
But I think the point you're making is actually a subtler point. It's not just about people who are talented leaving a community and going somewhere else. You're also losing someone who was an important relationship in your life. So in other words, there's an emotional loss in addition to any kind of professional or intellectual loss when someone leaves your community? Yes, and I think a loss that potentially makes your life worse, at least for a while, right? And I think the pandemic gives us a way to recognize this, right? Because some of us are feeling that loss that distance brings and how it makes our lives not as rich as they were before. And so I think in a way we can relate to that experience of having to distance ourselves
所以奋斗者想要摆脱他们的出身，但同时又觉得他们做不到。你讲了一个奥斯汀年轻人的故事，他把自己的生活比作桶里的螃蟹的故事。告诉我那个故事以及他的意思是什麽。是的，所以这个年轻人，我在书里给他起的名字叫朱兰（Juran）。他在奥斯汀一个主要由少数族裔组成的低收入社区长大。他的生活甚至比我之前谈到的托德的生活还要艰难得多。所以，朱兰的母亲对毒品上瘾，他的家庭生活非常混乱。
from people that we love and care about and feel that our lives are not as rich as they were in virtue of that. So strivers want to move on from their origins, but simultaneously feel like they can't. You tell the story of a young man from Austin who compared his life to the story of crabs in a bucket. Tell me that story and what he meant by it. Yeah, so this young man, the name I give him in the book is Juran. grew up in a predominantly minority low income neighborhood of Austin. And his life was much more difficult than even the life of Todd, who I talked about earlier. So, Joran's mother was addicted to drugs and his home life was very chaotic. To the point at which in high school he left home and was basically homeless and living on other peoples so fuss and he had a bucket in which he kept all his belongings.
以至于他在高中时离家出走，基本上无家可归，借宿在别人家，他有一个用来装所有随身物品的桶。他的足球教练发现了这个桶，并问他发生了什么事。朱兰把事情告诉了他，基本上这位教练收留了他并帮他申请了大学。朱兰在我采访他时，正在努力在大学里支持和他过去一样的学生。所以他的角色我想类似于住宿辅导员。因此他自己也做得很好。但有一
And his football coach found the bucket and sort of asked him what was going on. And Jaron told him, and basically this coach took him in and helped him apply to college. And Jaron, when I talked to him, was working to support exactly the kind of student he had been at a college. So he was, I think his role was something like a residential advisor. And so he had done really well for himself as well. But one
件他告诉我的事是，当他上大学时，他觉得自己必须彻底重塑自我，就像基本上从零开始。他不得不改变自己的风度、着装方式、说话方式、行为举止。他告诉我这是因为“桶里的螃蟹”。我从来没听过这个词。所以我问他是什么意思。然后他说，嗯，当一只螃蟹试图爬出桶时，其他螃蟹会把它拉下来。他害怕被拉下来
the thing that he told me about was that when he went to college, he felt like he had to completely reinvent himself, like basically start from scratch. He had to change his demeanor, how he dressed, how he talked, how he behaved. And he told me that that was because of crabs in a bucket. And I had never heard that phrase. So I asked him what he meant. Then he said, well, when a crab is trying to get out of a bucket, the other crabs are pulling them down. And he was afraid of getting pulled down
通过与他的社区保持联系或保留他旧自己的任何残余。所以他想，我必须把这一切抛在脑后，重新开始，这就是他成功的方式。当我们回来时，如何对抗作为奋斗者的伦理代价。请继续收听。哲学家詹妮弗·莫顿深入思考了向上流动、追求美国梦的一些伦理代价。其中很多来自于她的研究，但其中一部分也由她自己的故事所启发。詹妮弗，我了解到你主要是由祖母抚养长大的。请给我描述一下那段童年好吗？是的，我在秘鲁利马长大。我妈妈
by staying connected to his community or having any remnants of his old self remain. And so he thought, I have to leave all of that behind, start over, and that's how he made it. When we come back, how to battle the ethical cause of being a striver. Stay with us. Philosopher Jennifer Morton has thought deeply about some of the ethical costs of upward mobility, the pursuit of the American dream. A lot of this comes from her research, but some of it is also informed by her own story. Jennifer, I understand that you were largely raised by your grandmother. Can you describe that childhood for me please? Yeah, I grew up in Lima, Peru. My mom
17岁时怀上了我，80年代的秘鲁饱受恐怖主义、高通胀、政治不稳定之苦。我主要由祖母抚养长大，但我也有一位富有的阿姨，我母亲的妹妹嫁给了一个非常富有的人。因此我能够上一所非常昂贵的私立学校——利马美国学校。所以我不会说我是在贫困中长大的，
got pregnant with me when she was 17 and Peru in the 80s was beset by terrorism, high inflation, political instability. I mostly grew up with my grandmother, but I also had a wealthy aunt who, my mother's sister had married a very wealthy man. And so I was able to go to a very expensive private school, the American School of Lima. So I wouldn't say that I grew up poor,
按秘鲁的标准，我认为我们在中产阶级环境中长大。但我绝对有在工人阶级家庭长大的经历。我的祖母从秘鲁山区移民到利马。她是一名秘书，非常聪明，喜欢读报纸，但她绝对没有那种教育背景
and by the standard to Peru, I think we grew up middle class. But I definitely had the experience of growing up in a working class home. My grandmother had immigrated from the mountains of Peru to Lima. She was a secretary, very smart, loves reading the paper, but she definitely didn't have the kind of education
按秘鲁的标准来看，我认为我们是在中产阶级环境中长大的。但我绝对有在工薪阶层家庭长大的经历。我外祖母从秘鲁山区移民到利马。她是一名秘书，非常聪明，喜欢读报纸，但她确实没有那种教育背景。
that I saw my friends' parents had, because a lot of my friends were friends from school. So I grew up in kind of like having a working class family life and then going to school with extremely wealthy people and some of whom were, you know, the children of the prime minister or owners of big companies in our country. And so it was very strange. I grew up straddling these two worlds and that's I think where my interest in this topic started. So eventually you make it to the United States, you come to college to go to Princeton and most people might look at your story and say, okay, she's made it. I mean, this is terrific. She's at an Ivy League school. That's fantastic. This is her ticket up. But in many ways, you did not feel such confidence
我看到朋友的父母所拥有的生活，因为我的很多朋友都是学校里的同学。所以我成长在一种一边过着工人阶级家庭生活，一边和极其富有的人一起上学的生活环境中，其中有些人是，你知道的，首相的孩子或者是我们国家大公司的老板。所以这非常奇怪。我在成长过程中横跨这两个世界，我想我对这个话题的兴趣就是从那里开始的。所以你最终来到了美国，你来普林斯顿上大学，大多数人可能会看你的故事然后说，好吧，她成功了。我是说，这太棒了。她在常春藤盟校。这太棒了。这是她向上的门票。但在很多方面，你并没有那种自信
while you were at Princeton. Why not? There were a lot of aspects of being at college that I had trouble navigating, but I didn't really know who to ask. The story that sticks out in my mind is that I went to Princeton thinking that I would major in math or philosophy. And so I was placed into a very advanced math class because I had done very well in my international graduate math exam. And the first day I walked into this class, they were 40 or so students. I think there were only two or three other women and the professor never made eye contact with us, just wrote on the board. And the professor was famous
当你在普林斯顿时。为什么不呢？上大学有很多方面让我感到难以适应，但我真的不知道该问谁。我脑海中最突出的故事是，我怀着主修数学或哲学的想法去了普林斯顿。因此，我被分进了一个非常高级的数学班，因为我在国际研究生数学考试中表现得非常好。我走进这个班的第一天，里面大约有40名学生。我想只有两三个是女性，教授从不与我们对视，只是在黑板上写字。而且这位教授很有名
because he had just won a big prize. And so I was excited about taking a class with this famous mathematician, but nothing he said made sense to me. And I just assumed immediately, as I think a lot of students who are first-generation would in that situation, that I just wasn't well prepared and, you know, I should never take another math class again. Later, I found out that a lot of the students in that class
因为他刚赢得了一个大奖。所以能和这位著名的数学家一起上课我感到很兴奋，但他说的每一话我都不懂。我立刻就认为，正如我想很多第一代大学生在这种情况下都会做的那样，我只是没有做好准备，你知道，我再也不应该上任何数学课了。后来，我发现班上的很多学生
didn't know what was going on and that they had gone to talk to some other graduate students at these problem set sessions. And then my experience in a way hadn't been that dissimilar from theirs, but I immediately, because I think I felt very much like an outsider assumed that it was that and that I just didn't belong there.
都不知道发生了什么，他们去和这些习题课上的一些其他研究生交流了。从某种意义上说，我的经历和他们并没有太大不同，但我立刻，因为我觉得自己非常像个局外人，认为就是因为那个原因，我才不属于那里。
It's interesting, because drivers have to navigate very different identities. They often become exported, what is sometimes called code switching. You have two surnames, Morton and Galdos. I hope I'm pronouncing that correctly. You say that while you were at Princeton, Morton became the name of my American self and Galdos the name of my Peruvian self. Morton became my dominant public self
这很有趣，因为奋斗者必须驾驭非常不同的身份。他们经常被输出，有时被称为代码转换。你有两个姓氏，莫顿（Morton）和加尔多斯（Galdos）。我希望我发音正确。你说当你在普林斯顿时，莫顿成了我美国自我的名字，加尔多斯成了我秘鲁自我的名字。莫顿成了我主要的公众自我
when I live in the United States while Galdos sprang to life again on the streets of Lima during your trip's home. Tell me about this experience with Code Switching Jennifer. Yeah, so it's funny that I have the last name, Morton, because it's the name of my first step, dad. But it kind of enabled me to do this thing of compartmentalizing myself in a way
当我住在美国时，而加尔多斯在你的家乡之旅中，在利马的街头再次焕发生机。詹妮弗，跟我讲讲你这种代码转换的经历吧。是的，所以很有趣，我拥有莫顿这个姓氏，因为这是我继父的名字。但它在某种程度上使我能够做到将自己进行划分
between the person who is more at home in an American college versus the person, Galdos, who carries the name of my family back in Peru, who I am when I go back home. So I was always navigating these two worlds and still due to some extent, although now that I've been in America for so long, I feel like Morton has overtaken many aspects of my identity. I saw this and when I talked to the strivers for my book, a lot of them felt like they were navigating two identities.
在更习惯于美国大学的人与加尔多斯（保留着我在秘鲁的家人的姓氏，当我回家时我所是的那个我）之间。所以我一直在驾驭这两个世界，在某种程度上现在仍然如此，尽管我在美国呆了这么久之后，我觉得莫顿已经接管了我身份的许多方面。我看到了这一点，当我为我的书采访这些奋斗者时，他们中的许多人觉得他们正在驾驭两种身份。
They were going back and forth between the person they were at home or with their friends they grew up with, and the person that they were at work or at college or in their professional lives. And this kind of going back and forth can sometimes lead to some tension, right? And I think for some strivers, you might feel inauthentic sometimes in the professional world because there is a part of your identity or the way that you are or the way that you talk and that you're withholding You write I can now make a good living and spend most of my hours Engaged by work that I find fulfilling and rewarding
他们在他们在家时或与一起长大的朋友在一起时所扮演的人格，以及他们在工作、大学或职业生涯中所扮演的人格之间来回切换。这种来回切换有时会导致一些紧张感，对吧？我想对于一些奋斗者来说，你有时在职业世界中可能会觉得不真实，因为你的身份的一部分，或者你为人处世的方式，或者你说话的方式，被你隐去了。你写道：“我现在可以过上好日子，并将大部分时间投入到我发现能带来成就感和回报的工作中
But I am ever more distant from my country my culture culture, and crucially, the people I grew up with. Tell me about that, Jennifer. It sounds like you feel in some ways guilty that you have become disconnected from your roots in Peru. Yes, I do feel guilty, although, at the same time, I understand that there were a lot of factors involved in making it so that this was the path upward for me.
但我离我的国家、我的文化，以及最重要的是和我一起长大的人越来越远了。”詹妮弗，跟我讲讲那个吧。听起来你在某种程度上感到内疚，因为你与秘鲁的根基断了联系。是的，我确实感到内疚，但同时我也明白，有很多因素导致这条路成为了我向上的道路。
But it is hard, I think, to go back home and to feel not as comfortable and not as at-home as I used to feel and to have lost touch with many of the people that were a part of my life growing up. And so it is sad to me that I have become so disconnected from the community in which I grew up. Hmm. Do you feel like you want to do more for your grandmother and understand she still lives in Peru? Yeah, and I still talk to her fairly frequently.
但我想，回家却感觉不再像以前那么舒适、不再那么有宾至如归的感觉，并且与许多曾是我成长生活中一部分的人失去了联系，这确实很难。因此，我与我成长的社区失去了这么多的联系，这让我感到难过。嗯。你觉得自己想为祖母做更多的事吗？据我了解她仍然住在秘鲁？是的，我还是经常和她通话。
And one of the saddest aspects of the pandemic is not being able to go visit her or to have her come visit me. And I know that one of the sacrifices I made in coming here is not being able to be as close to my grandmother. And I was extremely close to her growing up. I mean, for me, she was the world. And now to not be able to be as close to her, it's a very painful cost. Hmm.
疫情最令人悲伤的方面之一就是无法去探望她，或者让她来探望我。我知道我来这里做出的牺牲之一就是不能和祖母那么亲近。我从小就和她非常亲近。我的意思是，对我来说，她就是整个世界。现在不能和她那么亲近，这是一个非常痛苦的代价。嗯。
You had a wonderful insight in the book about one way to overcome some of the ethical challenges of upward mobility. And this insight comes from your own family. You say that going back three generations now your family has been made up of immigrants, people who have basically migrated from one place to another, often looking for better economic opportunities. I'm wondering if you can describe for me how the frame of immigration might be a defense against some of the ethical
你在书中有一个绝妙的见解，关于克服社会向上流动的一些道德挑战的方法之一。这种见解来自于你自己的家庭。你说三代人以来，你的家庭一直由移民组成，这些人基本上从一个地方迁徙到另一个地方，通常是为了寻找更好的经济机会。我想知道你是否能为我描述一下，移民的框架如何能够成为抵御某些道德问题的防御机制
dilemmas we've talked about today? Yes, I think personally the immigrant narrative that I had really helped me navigate challenges that I faced as a college student as a graduate student because I think it does a few key things. So the first thing is that it acknowledges the value of what you're leaving behind. As immigrants know, we miss not just the people back home, but the food, the culture. There are all sorts of things that are valuable that we're leaving behind when we immigrate somewhere for economic opportunities. And the acknowledgement of that can be so important. And that's why I think when an educator is talking to a student, just acknowledging, it must be so hard that your brother is going through this
我们今天讨论过的困惑？是的，我认为个人而言，我所拥有的移民叙事确实帮助我应对了作为一名大学生、研究生所面临的挑战，因为我认为它起到了一些关键作用。所以第一件事是，它承认了你所抛弃的事物的价值。正如移民所知，我们不仅想念家乡的人，还想念食物、文化。当我们为了经济机会移民到某个地方时，我们抛弃的有价值的东西形形色色。对这一点的认可非常重要。这就是为什么我认为当教育工作者与学生交谈时，只要承认一句，你的兄弟正在经历这些，你却无法陪在他身边，这一定很难
and you can't be there for them. That can really be quite powerful. But I think also immigrants know that they're making these trade-offs. I was taught from very early on that you're going to have to go somewhere else to find an opportunity. And that will come at a cost. It might be, you might feel sad, you might feel lonely. It might be challenging to navigate this new culture, this new community. And it helps the person tell themselves a
这确实能产生很大的力量。但我认为移民也知道他们正在做出这些权衡。我从小就被教导，你必须去其他地方寻找机会。这会付出代价。可能会是这样，你可能会感到难悲伤，你可能会感到孤独。适应这种新文化、这个新社区可能具有挑战性。它帮助人们向自己讲述一个
story about the challenges that they're confronting, that it's not just about them. And I need to figure out a way to understand the situation so that I can succeed. You had an insight in the book that I thought was really interesting. You point out that there are lots of Peruvians who made a different choice than you did. They could have left Peru, but they chose to stay. And you're right, it would be preposterous for me to blame my fellow Peruvians who chose to stay, even if as a result, their educational or economic achievements were diminished.
关于他们正在面对的挑战的故事，这不仅仅关于他们自己。我需要想办法理解这种情况，以便我能成功。你在书中有一个见解，我认为非常有趣。你指出，有许多秘鲁人做出了与你不同的选择。他们本可以离开秘鲁，但他们选择留下来。你说得对，如果我去指责那些选择留下的秘鲁同胞，哪怕因此他们的教育或经济成就受到了影响，那也是荒谬的。
Yet it's not unusual to hear or read that same sentiment about those who remain in impoverished communities in the United States. That's a really interesting insight, Jennifer. Talk about that. Yes, I think when we start to see the sacrifices that people have to make in order to be upwardly mobile, we start to see why people might not choose that path. So in the case of myself,
然而，听到或读到对美国贫困社区留守人员抱有同样看法的言论并不罕见。这是一个非常有趣的见解，詹妮弗。谈谈那个吧。是的，我认为当我们开始看到人们为了实现社会向上流动而不得不做出的牺牲时，我们开始明白为什么人们可能不会选择那条路。所以在我的例子中，
I saw that there were lots of people who stayed at home. And I think it would be preposterous, as I say in the book for me to think that they were being irrational or to blame them or to hold them to account for doing that. In some ways they were choosing valuable aspects of their lives over economic advancement, whether that was thing close to family or friends, or being somewhere where they felt at home and where their identities were valued. And so I think there's a lot to be said for being deeply rooted and connected to a place. And so I think in the case of students and young people who are growing up in concentrated poverty in
我看到有很多人留在了家里。我认为正如我在书中说的，如果我认为他们是不理智的，或者去责备他们，或者让他们为这样做负责，那是荒谬的。在某种程度上，他们是在用生活中宝贵的方面来换取经济上的进步，无论是与家人或朋友保持亲密，还是在一个让他们感到宾至如归并且其身份受到重视的地方。因此，我认为深深扎根并连接到一个地方有很多值得称道的地方。所以我想，在那些在集中贫困地区长大的学生和年轻人的情况下
the United States, there's a similar rhetoric that opportunities are elsewhere and that they would be lucky to leave, and then puzzlement that those who might have been able to leave and don't leave as if they're making some sort of mistake. But I don't think in many cases they are making a mistake. They are prioritizing other valuable things in their lives over economic advancement and opportunity. Jennifer Morton is a philosopher at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill, she's the author of Moving Up Without Losing Your Way. Jennifer, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you.
在美国，有一种类似的言论，即机会在别处，离开他们就会很幸运，然后对于那些本可以离开却没有离开的人感到困惑，就好像他们在犯某种错误一样。但我不认为在很多情况下他们在犯错。他们是在将生活中其他有价值的事情置于经济进步和机会之上。詹妮弗·莫顿（Jennifer Morton）是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的哲学家，她是《向上流动而不迷失自我》（Moving Up Without Losing Your Way）的作者。詹妮弗，感谢你今天来到《隐秘的大脑》。谢谢你。
This was fantastic, Shengor. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midrall Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our run sun hero this week is Alice Yeh.
这太棒了，香卡（Shankar）。《隐秘的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。Midrall Media 是我们的独家广告销售伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐秘的大脑》的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是爱丽丝·叶（Alice Yeh）。
Alice is a PhD student at the University of Chicago and she did a fellowship at NPR some time ago. Working remotely from home, Alice went on a great, sleuthing expedition for us, identifying a number of guests for our show. If you enjoyed our conversation today with Jennifer Morton, you have Alice to thank for finding her. We're so grateful for your help, Alice, and wish you the best of luck as you finish your PhD.
爱丽丝是芝加哥大学的博士生，她不久前在美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）做过研究员。爱丽丝在家里远程工作，为我们进行了一次伟大的侦探考察，为我们的节目确定了许多嘉宾。如果你喜欢今天与詹妮弗·莫顿的对话，你得感谢爱丽丝找到了她。我们非常感谢你的帮助，爱丽丝，并祝你在完成博士学位时好运。
We're working on some new episodes and looking for great personal stories that reveal interesting psychological concepts. Was there ever a time in your life when your own behavior shocked you? Were you found yourself asking, who is this person? If you're willing to share a personal story about such a time, please find a quiet room and record a short voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at ideasathydnbrain.org.
我们正在制作一些新的节目，并寻找能揭示有趣心理学概念的伟大个人故事。你生命中可曾有过这样的时刻，你自己的行为让你大吃一惊？你是否发现自己在问，这个人是谁？如果你愿意分享关于这样一个时刻的个人故事，请找一个安静的房间，在你的手机上录下一段简短的语音备忘录。通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。
That email address again is ideasathyd hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Be sure to include your name and phone number and use the subject line stranger. If you like today's episode, we have two requests for you. Please tell one friend about hidden brain. And if you haven't already, please subscribe to the podcast so you get our episodes every Monday. Thank you for listening. I'm Shankar Vedanta. See you next week. you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那个电子邮件地址再次是：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。那个电子邮件地址再次是：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请务必附上你的姓名和电话号码，并使用主题行“陌生人（stranger）”。如果你喜欢今天的节目，我们有两个请求。请告诉一位朋友关于《隐秘的大脑》的事。如果你还没订阅，请订阅播客，以便你每周一都能收到我们的节目。感谢收听。我是香卡·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedanta）。下周见。你 你 这个单集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。